>> Jesse: FOR TWO WEEKS NOW
"PRIMETIME" TEAM HAS BEEN
FIGHTING A WAR ON CHRISTMAS
HAPPENING IN THE TINY TOWN OF
DEDHAM, MASSACHUSETTS.
IT STARTED WHEN A PERSNICKETY
LIBRARIAN BANNED CHRISTMAS TREES
IN THE LIBRARIES BECAUSE THEY
MADE PEOPLE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE.
GOOD NEWS "PRIMETIME" INTERVENED
AND THE TREES ARE BACK.
THE PEOPLE OF DEDHAM
MASSACHUSETTS ARE VERY HAPPY
WITH WHAT UNFOLDED.
MANY SAY IT'S BEEN AN ATTACK ON
CHRISTIANITY AND LAST NIGHT THEY
CROWDED INTO THE TOWN HALL AND
SPOKE DIRECTLY TO THE LIBRARY
BOARD.
WATCH.
>> I HAVE TO ASK THAT YOU.
>> THE CHRISTMAS TREE IS A
SYMBOL OF CHRISTIANITY.
>> IF HAVE YOU ANY FURTHER
COMMENT YOU ARE WELCOME TO EMAIL
US.
>> ASSOCIATED WITH IT TO OTHERS.
AS A TAX PAYING MEMBER OF THIS
COMMUNITY, WE SHOULD ALL BE
REPRESENTED, NOT JUST THOSE
PEOPLE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WHY DO YOU HATE CHRISTIANS SO
MUCH?
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT A CHRISTMAS
TREE.
THIS IS ABOUT TRYING TO LEAD THE
TOWN INTO BEING WOKE.
THESE PEOPLE NOW ARE WATCHING.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO PUT UP IT
W. IT ANYMORE.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I'M NOT HERE TONIGHT TO
DEFEND ANYTHING.
ONE THING I AM HERE TO DO
TONIGHT IS TO SAY THAT THE
CHRISTMAS TREE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
UP.
>> I'M JEWISH.
FOR ME, CHRISTMAS IS -- SORRY.
CHRISTMAS IS A TIME OF PEACE.
IT'S A TIME WE SHOULD GIVE
RESPECT TO EVERYBODY.
>> I'M SAD HAVING BEEN A LIFE
RESIDENT OF THIS TOWN THAT THE
BOARD DIDN'T SAY ANYTHING EXCEPT
THAT THEY WERE STILL DECORATING
AND WORKING ON -- ON A
CONVERSATION THAT HAPPENED BACK
IN THE SPRING.
>> THERE HAS BEEN A TREE IN THIS
TOWN FOR 30 YEARS AT THE
LIBRARY.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S NOT
THERE THIS YEAR.
SO, IT WAS DISTURBING.
>> YOU DECIDED NOT TO HAVE A
TREE FOR WHATEVER BIASES THAT
YOU MAY HAVE.
YOU THOUGHT NOBODY WAS GOING TO
FIND OUT ABOUT IT.
THANKFULLY MRS. SAID SOMETHING.
THANK YOUFULLY TURTLE BOY PICKED
UP THE STORY.
THANKFULLY JESSE WATTERS PICKED
THE LOCAL MEDIA PICKED UP THE
STORY AND NOW YOU ARE JUST
SITTING IN THE PILE OF POOP THAT
YOU MADE FOR YOURSELF.
>> I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT NOW IF
I HAD LITTLE KIDS I WOULD MOVE
AWAY BECAUSE OF ALL OF YOU
PEOPLE.
DON'T HAVE THE COURAGE TO STAND
UP AND DO WHAT WAS RIGHT.
YOU EMBARRASSED US ALL OVER A
TREE.
>> Jesse: OUR FEARLESS FOOT
SOLDIER LISA DESMOND WAS AT THE
MEETING AND TRIED TO KEEP THE
PEACE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, ALL THESE
PEOPLE WANT IS FOR THE HOLIDAYS
TO BE CELEBRATED.
HOPEFULLY THE TOWN LEARNS FROM
THIS AND PERHAPS NEXT YEAR THEY
CAN SPEED UP THE DECORATION
REVIEW PROCESS SO THAT THE TREES
CAN GO UP BE